Instagram is blowing up with black
looking food and beauty products
thanks to this stuff it's called
activated charcoal or activated carbon
its what health trend fanatics claimed
to be using to detox brighten skin and
whiten their teeth but of course just
because you can wash with it
eat it and brush your teeth with it
doesn't mean you necessarily should the
global market for activated charcoal is
projected to reach 6.2 billion dollars
by 2022 it's an impressive feat
considering it comes from the same stuff
as your grilling charcoal its da-da-da
burnt wood the difference is that
activated charcoal is burned at a higher
temperature so it breaks down into a
very fine powder which gives it a larger
surface area than a chunk of charcoal on
your grill and it's exactly what you
want when you're trying to remove toxins
or poison from your body how it works
has to do with the microscopic structure
of the charcoal itself inside each
particle are millions of pores that act
like a tiny trap so if you swallow some
then it will begin to bind with other
substances in your gut which is helpful
if you've just overdosed on drugs since
it can prevent them from entering your
system and in fact this is exactly what
hospitals will use to treat certain
cases of poisoning before resorting to
pumping the stomach but drugs aren't the
only thing that charcoal binds to it can
also soak up helpful things like
minerals vitamins and antioxidants so
when you drink a charcoal laced lemonade
with a healthy meal you're actually
absorbing less nutrients than you
otherwise would to make matters worse it
can also prevent medications like
antidepressants and contraceptive pills
from reaching your system which of
course makes them less effective the key
to activated charcoal whether it's
saving a life or depriving you of
nutrition is timing it
only works if there's something for it
to absorb in the first place so bad news
taking charcoal pills in the morning for
a hangover it's not gonna do anything
bail because the alcohol is long gone
from your stomach by then so ingesting
charcoal for any other reason than
treating a severe case of poisoning
isn't a good idea
it's indigestible so after you eat it
your body passes it along and eventually
out the other end but along the way it
can have side effects Oh fun like
constipation and nausea not to mention
there is sorry no evidence to support
the claims from charcoal enthusiasts
that it will prevent bloating boost
energy brighten skin or whiten teeth so
hey if you don't like the idea of eating
black you know anything you don't have
to your body's probably better off
anyway